only your hatred can destroy me star
wars the last Jedi this is uh is gonna
be an interesting one now before I
actually get into things I'm gonna
preface this with a couple of things the
first is I have been going so far out of
my way to avoid every single piece of
marketing ever since the first trailer
came out I saw the first trailer I've
avoided every trailer since every
article I've watched no reviews I
haven't even seen the Rotten Tomatoes
score so as I am recording this having
now seen the movie I have no idea what
the general consensus on this movie is
or have any sense of what people do or
don't like about it what you're getting
from me right now is just me I haven't
even talked to my friends who have seen
it yet now I am gonna be getting into
spoilers but that'll be a little bit
I'll start with a short spoiler free
version so that people who want to know
my opinion but don't want to know
suppose or I haven't seen it yet can
move on there are parts that are good
even great basically everything that
centers are round Luke Leia Rey and kylo
Ren is great the rest of it I have
issues with and I can't really detail
those issues without getting more into
spoilers but what I will say is the the
aspects of the story that don't center
around those characters who I named
drags along at a snail's pace and feels
patted in the worst way
and to detail that is to get into
spoilers so that's just boiler free
let's get into this this thing opened
wonderfully I love the opening battle it
was wonderful it was 10 so you got to
see Poe do awesome post up but it also
gave him a really good starting point
and actually I
named PO among my characters that I
loved everything about but he still had
some really good moments he started out
really well and I like where he ends he
actually he probably has more of an arc
in terms of actually ending up in a
different place than he started than any
other character in this movie because it
seems like a lot of the other characters
who go through arcs like have a dip but
then end up very similar to where they
started at the beginning of the movie he
actually feels like he goes through a
bit more of a journey and he changes his
approach and his thinking as to how the
best way to do this fight is and the
opening with the dread the Dreadnought
was an impressive intimidating piece of
equipment I was impressed with that and
all that stuff
terrific great then we get to the island
now the the island stuff was a little
slow but I was kind of okay with that I
kind of expected that because you know
the obvious parallel comparison is the
dig above stuff in returning the not
return Jedi uh Empire Strikes Back and
so I was kind of expecting that to be a
little bit slow paced and it was going
like it was okay and then they
established the connection between kylo
Ren and Rey and I liked that I liked it
just as a concept I like the way that it
played out I liked what it brought out
of each of those characters I loved the
way they played off each other I really
liked all of that stuff the stuff we
found out about Luke and in terms of
sort of the background and what had gone
on what none of it was excessively
shocking but I think it all played
pretty well the Yoda cameo was great I
thought that was terrific
like I said lei is really good lay up
she gets some real moments to shy and I
will straight up I teared up when she
was out in space and she opened her eyes
again and she liked force pulled her way
back to the ship
I yeah that that brought a tear to my
eye that was a that was good stuff
oh god kylo Ren facing down Luke first
of all what a great fight that was and
then the revelation that Luke was never
even there and then you realize the
hints that were right in front of you
cuz I know
very early on they drew attention to it
the fact that you know kylo Ren he's
leaving footprints Luke is not and I
thought it was just a matter of oh god
he's so down with the force like he
leaves no trace or anything like that
was like no he's not even there like
that way that was a really good really
triumphant reveal that nope he hadn't
even been there the entire time and it
also like fixed some things cuz he
turned on the lights and we're like
what's that the lightsaber that just got
split in half what's going on that but
I'm good now I know why he wasn't even
really there and the way the fight was
going makes more sense cuz he he wasn't
blocking anything kylo Ren did he was
just dodging he was avoiding contact at
all costs and as cool as the whole you
know they bombard him with everything
they've gotten he's still there thing is
I'm glad it was a fake out because
honestly that otherwise that's like
really because we saw a whole bunch of
Jedi Masters get dumped getting gunned
down by clone troopers back in Revenge
of the Sith and I know a lot of fans my
age and older don't like revenge this is
said that we'd like to pretend it didn't
happen but like this dead seemed 'islam
reasonable but again then you realize
he's not even there
Oh awesome cool so that that kind of
stuff good even great I mean I I think
that Adam driver is is really becoming
an MVP of this series he I'm really
loving watching him and the you cuz you
he delivers the struggle really well and
so did Mark Hamill as Luca but what he
delivered really well was the pain of
his failures like how he couldn't let
those go and then Yoda giving him the
absolute perfect advice that failure is
the most important thing that we can
learn from like that was exactly what he
did here and that was great so now that
appraised all that stuff here's the
problems with this thing I mentioned the
padding and what I mean by the padding
is we start out and they had they are
escaping and they are trying to get away
from the the first order
and they need PO to basically slow them
down long enough for them to get away
cool he does that he loses they end up
losing more people as a result of his
plan than Leia is comfortable with I
like that she appreciates the value of
each like being lost that's a nice touch
but so okay so that happens and they get
away then they get caught up to again
and now they are very slowly running
away and they need to figure out a way
to stall this the ship best following
them and keep fleeing okay great
it just seems like this is kind of a
repeat of the issue we just had but okay
how do we do that well we got a turn off
the this sensor thing the tracker on the
ship great terrific boo so this great
this is a mission for them to go in
infiltrate awesome oh no but see we
can't do that yet cuz first you gotta go
find this Cobra okay well where's the
Cobra
well you gotta go here is this a well no
see now you're arrested you're in jail
you know what it feels like it feels
like when you're playing a video game
and you get given a very specific
mission like you got to do this you go
great let's do it and the game goes ah
no it's sidequest time you got to go off
and do this other thing so that you get
the resource you need to do this main
quest like oh okay well you know side
quests are fun they're their way to open
these up give us some new locations gay
a couple of fun characters cool I'll go
on this side quest and then you start
doing the side quest and as you're about
to get to the thing that will complete
the side quest so you can do the main
quest you get another road sign says ah
you can't complete this side quest until
you go off on this other side quest to
get the thing you need so you can get
the thing you need so you can actually
do the main quest that's what it feels
like with this whole going to this
casino planet to find a codebreaker to
stop the tracker there's one note to
find a codebreaker
to then get to go through all of the
effort of trying to get on the ship to
stop the tracker to then finally try and
get away and then
Laura Dern's character who's fine I mean
I also clarify this none of the
performances are bad all the
performances are fine
and some of the ones I mentioned already
are great but she I get that she's a I
give you orders you just follow them
kind of person and she has a different
way of leading and she rubs up against
PO get it fine but once it's very clear
that he is really not listening and he
is antsy and he's kind of hard to
control why would you just not tell it
why would you not just tell him what the
plan is if the plan is we're gonna cloak
these smaller ships and go down to this
planet why wouldn't you tell him that
especially considering like after he has
a mutiny and gets stunned and put on one
of these ships and gets told the plan he
goes oh that's a pretty good plan yes it
is maybe if she told it to him he
wouldn't have had to do a frigging
mutiny like what what was the point of
that yes I get it feeds into Poe's
little arc that I've already
complimented but like that's dumb we get
the new character of Rose who's fine she
was okay
Benicio del Toro I forgot he was in this
he turned up I was like okay and then he
started talking my oh we got our latest
trademark Benicio del Toro weird voice
he's got a starter this time that's new
and again he was fine but yeah yeah he
was tight he was tied up in the side
quest to get to do the side quest so I
was kind of inherently annoyed with him
because he fed into something that I
already didn't like and then even beyond
that whole thing they get down to this
planet and the first order Falls them
down and they have to set up this cannon
and we get this whole thing okay we
gotta take these speeders out to take
out this cannon so he can get away and
I'm thinking didn't we just do this two
times before actually isn't this how the
movie opened and isn't this like the
whole thing with the cruiser and like
trying to get away from the from Snoke
ship like
if our we effectively doing the same
thing three times in one movie I got
really mixed feelings on Snoke to Andy
Serkis does a really good job playing
him I like the look of him he is
intimidating but we're probably never
gonna get answers on this guy now
because he's dead in a good scene a good
way and it was a good moment for kylo
Ren observe that his death worked but
there's now no reason for them to ever
tell us who the hell he was because it
doesn't matter cuz he's dead and
understand this isn't me needing a
validation for like some pet fan theory
I have I haven't really cared who he was
but part of the reason I didn't care who
he was because I always assumed we would
get an answer so and like I don't always
need answers like I didn't ever need to
know who the Emperor was because like
well I know the Empire's evil he's the
head of that do I really need to know
much more than that
honestly I don't which is you know one
of the many fall downs of the prequels
because he focuses on the rise of the
sky like I didn't need to know his
background but in the case of Snoke
there's like how does he how he fits
into this this little [ __ ] we've gotten
just raised a bajillion questions that
don't get answered like India not just
in from the previous movie in this one
too because Luke is all like Snoke
already poisoned his heart okay
how who the hell was he where did he
come from how did he know to go to kylo
Ren how did he contact him like what
what who and again I don't need like a
massive detailed history of the rise of
the first order I in my personal being
it doesn't really matter enough time
passed between the original trilogy and
this that I can just kind of roll with
another you know something came in and
co-opted the resources and the imagery
of the Empire and became its own worst
thing I can't just roll with that but
like you've drawn specific attention to
the fact that this guy who's leading it
like is a force user and specifically
went after kylo Ren like that raised
is way too many questions and you can't
just ignore them you could have if you
hadn't brought them up in the first
place and he had just been the guy who
leads this thing but he wasn't he was
more than that and now like what foods
the hell I do want to say we did get
answers to one question we actually got
the answers that I always wanted but I
didn't think we were gonna get and
that's in regards to Rey her parents or
nobody I love that that that was what I
wanted in the first movie but I I
assumed we were never gonna get that cuz
it was all this heavy foreshadowing of
who's her parents where did you get this
power from her parents are nobody
she's just strong with the force oh yes
because they the Skywalker's are not the
end-all be-all of everything somebody
new can come along and be great it
doesn't have to be tied to this family
and this bloodline it could just be
anybody or a nobody loved it but I gotta
tell you I I think you know I've been
bouncing back and forth between things I
I did and didn't like cuz the things
that I like I like a lot and the things
that I don't like I really don't like it
more to the point I don't understand how
that happened
like the the whole way that that that
the thing is padded and repetitive like
how did that happen like I don't I don't
I don't get it
because this is this is just basic
storytelling stuff but you did don't do
that so it just was really frustrating I
think ultimately it's not bad I wouldn't
say it's flat-out bad it's it's worth
seeing it's it's fun and like I said
when it's good it's great but it's
probably my least favorite Star Wars
film excepting the prequels so episodes
1 2 3 set those aside those are
absolutely at the bottom but it's my
least favorite of what's left I like it
less than the force awakens I like it
less than rogue 1 I like it less than
Return of the Jedi and
new hope I like it less than all those
but I did use the phrase least-favorite
as opposed to it's the worst because
they I do still enjoy it but this this
does this goes down as a as a
disappointment for me and like I said at
the time of recording I have no idea if
I am about to get piled on by all the
fans who think I'm an idiot because
everyone has declared this thing
brilliant and it's got a 90 whatever on
Rotten Tomatoes or if I'm actually
vocalizing an opinion that is more
widely shared I have no idea I suppose
I'll find out depending on whether or
not I get crucified in the comments for
this one but Star Wars the last Jedi
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it please have them be more
in-depth and polite than just telling me
that I'm an idiot don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks have a listen to the
council of geeks podcast that's
available on Apple podcast and stitcher
radio I'm also someone happy to punch
like your girl podcast that is a
presentation of the fire water podcast
network Fire and Water podcast comm
links for all the stuff is down below
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]